[Music]
I was like reading about the Met gal and
I was like oh I want to go I was like
okay she should go to this and I'm I
give you a good psychic we just did a
massive brainstorm of all our options so
we thought of Paparazzi we're going to
be celeb stylists we found out that this
major magazine was going to be there and
we thought that maybe we could be a part
of it
yeah we decided to order an Uber black I
decided to stop the car and we rolled
down the window and I just asked the
police where's the entrance to the Met
Gala and they were like right this way
when we hold around the corner was the
line of huge black cars filled with
celebrities there's a huge SUV in front
of us and they opened the door and it
was Nicki Minaj so we kind of are
panicking and like we can't turn back we
try and go to the Press entrance so
pretty much the guy said no we went to
the bathroom and kind of realized like
it wasn't gonna work